alors du coup ce matin il y avait un
conseil stratégique chez LR donc 19
signataires de la motion de censure
est-ce que vous vous savez si leur sort
a été tranché selon vous il faut faire
quelque
chose divisé moi je pense que ce qu'il
faut surtout dire ce pourquoi on est
pour tous ensemble et pas ce pourquoi on
est contre chacun de son côté et donc
c'est chercher à rassembler et savoir
quel est notre projet commun aujourd'hui
et pas notre stratégie personnelle
contre Emmanuel Macron contre un projet
c'est vraiment
ce qui nous rassemblent qu'il faut les
rechercher et aujourd'hui on n'y est pas
mais c'est pas illogique après plusieurs
défaites historiques
soit au présidentielle que ce soit aux
européennes
au législatif ou on est quand même pas
sorti grandit il faut aller chercher
après l'élection d'élections un peu de
bon sens un peu de force et pas de la
faiblesse dans la division le
parti 70
c'est un peu simple c'est oublier toutes
les défections à la République en marche
chez redescence au modem c'est parce
qu'il manquait des voix à cet endroit là
qu'on avait besoin de toutes les voix
chez LR s'il y a des divisions partout
le pays est fracturé je pense que
Emmanuel Macron qui voulait faire une
disruption à réussir y compris dans son
camp qu'il avait inventé à mettre
aujourd'hui le pays par terre
c'est un exploit et c'est bien de sa
faute à lui faute de méthode
faute du moment choisi
il y a là une responsabilité toute
particulière du président de la
République
non c'est parce qu'on utilise les sujets
à mauvais escient
quand après 60 ans la Constitution va
donc fait ses preuves de sa solidité y
compris dans les épreuves donc c'est pas
cela le sujet c'est la pratique des
institutions qui est catastrophique et
c'est là où on voit effectivement quand
le pratique mal et bien on a des
violences dans une société qui a changé
à l'intérieur demain pour recoudre la
situation la fin la crise je suis pas
sûr que pour reco la situation il
fallait passer sur un texte d'abord
immigration puis fin de vie puis réforme
des institutions je pense qu'il faut
d'abord mettre ce qui est en commun
avant de mettre ce qui divise
profondément le pays en place il est le
président de la République il va au
journal de 13h bientôt il fera les
quatre vérités le matin
j'entends rien de lui et l'AS je vous
remercie monsieur
c'est pas le choix le choix du Trésor ce
n'est pas le choix de la France qui
travaille donc je crois que la réforme
des retraites c'est eux qui vont subir
le poids et donc j'aurais d'abord parlé
à la France qui travaille avant de
parler à la France des retraités
par exemple
[Musique]